this video is sponsored by liquid
IV more on them after the reaction
people what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation I joined with Aon Alexander here
to watch a classic comedy that I don't know about
only thing we know is Andrew Gordon decided to do
his impression of the main character saying
his name that's all I needed to know you did
that yesterday remember he like a major pain or I
don't know what he said I vaguely remember I tune
him out it's major pain we're watching today Aaron
how are you you know what I got this this uh this
I got my sciatica acting up so it's real it's a
real major pain in my side do you really have a
sciatica thing or no my mom does though you just
wanted to make that major pain J it did it was it
was a stretch but you know we made it we made it
here we arrived yeah good good video hey top tier
comedy baby like on this video also subscribe
click that Bell to get notified when we got a
reaction up for something else on this channel
tell us in your the comments in your comments
what you think about the major pain or if there's
other comedy classic comedies you think we should
check out prepper thank you for editing this down
full length re watch sing with your own copy of
MJ pain is available for our super sex rejects
over at our patreon page over there we cover
several things exclusively with highlights and
watch SS included Aaron you ready to do this I'm
ready Sergeant yep yep yep that's how he sounds
that's Andrew's impression rough watch let's do
this [Music]
oh born to be damn okay double Universal
let's go p p to the phone porn of you wild
stupid you
repetitive on the day I was born Born
to Be [Laughter] Wild wife and
kids that's the name of his show
okay I thought this came out beforehand I guess
it was during it might have name his production
company oh dang the
hell I'm triggered badass follow
me damn it's like they opening a Terminator
[Music]
oh my God he's like a super badass
he's good at his job Miss shot okay
oh that's not funny me show you
little trick take your mind out
that that you may feel a little fresh
e e Jesus it
to what was the objective man to distract
him from his arm it's horrible absolutely
horrible Aaron you can't argue with his methods
major pain [Music] indeed you had better give
up seor you cannot kill us all no but I can
clean your quick no thank you burritos with
extra guac were like o the promotion board
report came out last week this is the new
lieutenant colonel list your name is not on it
two chances to advance then we got to show you
the hatch the hatch you trying to tell me in
all this man's military there's no room left
for a trained weapon of Destruction the gold
to is killing man you got to be somebody needs
some [Music] killing anybody you've killed
them all you've killed them all every single
one you're too good at your job man like how
he's playing it with a sense of sincerity whole
week since I killed me a man and already I'm
get the itch problem is I ain't got nothing to
scratch God I'm hungry you're
going to find something just
you wait oh hell no blood no no no no I'm just
playing oh [Music]
no it's like Apocalypse Now I got to keep
my strength up got to maintain discipline
because yeah this is Apocalypse Now this
is a dramatization of a domestic violence
dispute you arrive on the scene to find a
woman played by Miss Goodman claiming to
have been assaulted by her husband played
by Mr Shipman happy to meet you s this is
going to go terrible your objective is
to effectively neutralize the situation
uhoh WR choice of words uhoh oh he knows it's
killing he hit me uhoh you like to beat women
you like to beat women that is a
jail that's hilarious he's too good at his
job what happened you've only been out one
week it's cilian life sir I had a Mana set man
I got an assignment for you it's not great you
understand but it gets you back in the military
he's so thirsty for it he's so ready for violence
it's not a spoof of the military vets it's a
spoof of the movies that do this oh yeah smart
I was told it would be my greatest challenge it
was sure to be a living hell all right let's see
it you like a boarding school or something the
G Club will be meeting 3 give be a teacher oh
my God keep this man far away from children Tiger
Tiger come back here I'm not going to chase you
what a cool name a no he's going to build up
some real morale in these children he's going
to teach them about The Facts of Life what you
running from boy she's trying to get me a shot
you don't like needles want me to show you a
little trick take your mind off that pain oh
no no please don't do it now you may be a little
bit of a PR no don't do it not to the not to the
little boy counselor Hillary oh [__] for
fresh yeah that's a fine handshake you got
you you [Music] want come on nice meeting
you major nice meeting you Miss ma'am but
she's playing a smart person what up
of her [Laughter] range oh your place
girl pull together man maor pain reporting
for Duty sir thought that was a fart sound
same yep you're in charge of the green boys they
wear those green things is that a beetle walking
across in front of bushes I can't see them did
they get real bugs it looks like it I understand
you've been placing last eight years running into
Virginia Military games I am here to remedy that
I don't care what you do with those boys as long
as you keep them out of my hair falling movie you
idiots let's go oh he's going to have his work cut
out for him Aaron oh Lord he's going to have his
work cut out for him he's going to have to whip
these Misfits into shape they're a bunch of dweeps
nerds even major Bon W pain as of I am replacing
maor Frankford as your [Music] [Laughter] [Music]
commanding whoa what are you doing man
now what we have here is a failure to
communicate to turn you maggots into a well
disciplined Cadet unit from this day for what
you're sorry asn't Belong To Me Drake blow
your nose or even dig in your butts without
my say so it's a lot of rules killing
is my business ladies and business is
good I have to go to the bathroom
you hold it [Laughter] I said hold
it or I'll break that up and kick it around on the
ground I've heard some of these quotes but I never
knew they were from this movie I did something
B is that Orlando Bloom Orlando Brown I mean go
change your hugging boy and be back here fronto
stop that cry a you think your tears will
stop Charlie from taking his b and sticking
in your little tiny heart he's going to have
to learn to be softer what the hell was that
you little Freckle face cartoon this move is
going to have a lot more heart than expected
that's what I'm thinking did I give you
permission to sneeze open no sir hold it
in you big turd otherwise I kick your ass back
to no wrong person drop down give me 25 pushup
one
uhoh what are you laughing at pig
boy ouch you know you remind me of
the dough boy if I poke your stomach will make you
[Laughter] go up right now let go let
me see that roll oh God let me see that
belly roll who you red fox do y'all not
learn bro WR this kid what's your name
girlfriend call me dick you call me
you like the way I handle the white
boy feel good black man run back yeah brother
why you come close ah I not your damn brother
now me Squad now this is great what are you
looking at ass ass nothing sir you plotting
on me boy no sir well let me tell you something
ass ass eyes and when a man get eyb at me and
make my asent jack up and I get the to kill you
me so you Jesus and what is your damage muscle
head you ignorant or you just plain old death yes
sir he is Dea oh oh oh damn I'm sorry Mr handicap
man if you don't answer me when I speak to you
I'm going to put my foot in your [Laughter] ass
no oh God course the ADR that line hey guys
who's this guy he's the cool kid looks like
we got another major on our hands here guys
oh [__] he's the one who wields the real
power oh wow I think he really shaved his
head oh damn they all really shaved their
heads you will walk like me talk like me oh
poor guys all right d take these men two hour
a PT yes sir first exercise will be the side
[Laughter] Str I love his fervor there were
these kind of like 90s movies of stranger
mentoring students and some capacity yeah
there's a theme there could you please
help me to understand why you shave the
children bals oh that's my little incentive
program these boys had to earn it do that
is do they have to earn their bathroom
privileges too told on him he's upset
about this morning apparently he had a little
accident apparently he pissed all over the front
of his pants well maybe that's because he's six
woman when I was six years old I had a full-time
job
a full time job you think I owe you an
apology I'm sorry you're just a little
turd that can't hold your liquid out
in public oh you get on out in my face
while I pick you up and toss you out that
window adorable I think that has a little kid
in fresh prins I think that's little Orlando
Brown ah damn I don't know I'm likely
to trust your instincts for no specific
reason do you know what positive
reinforcement means you take a PO
and you snap his neck after you TOR him so you
don't have to go through life with a colost
bag I'd like to make a suggestion why don't
you and I become Partners emotional growth
and development of these little ones oh that's
an interesting turn what do you say I would
say yes I mean look at her I can't look at her
she's too unattractive oh my go she's talking
sexual yes yes good oh she knew what she was
doing of course of course she does you women
ruining me you'll be the death of me man
that damn pain already starting to get on
my nails while he's eating candy they're
counterproductive there buddy get off ow
what a jerk bag Pain's going to kill us you
know I have a heart condition I'm not sure
he's familiar with my medical history I have
good news for you [__] pack your beding your
kid and your clothes let's go welcome to the
House of Pain house oh my God he got so many
snacks sir I think I speak for everyone when I
say that this place is unacceptable what are you
doing
[Music]
really the absurdity of the drill sergeants my
little sprout uproot yourselves I like that shot
tomorrow L we going to start the hard stuff they
really put these children through the ringer you
get no sympathy from me you want sympathy look at
the dictionary between [__] [Laughter] simp you
really makes this movie he's so funny yeah don't
fly baby fly I love that guy he's so good if we
don't get across that rope I'mma hang him with
it they'll hang you with it he loves it over
that take your fat over shut up come on he can't
do it leave him alone I can barely do it everyone
really looks up to him he's like the real leader
yeah he could be there's a lot of potential in him
they're feel they're going to earn each other's
Respect by the end of the F end of the movie what
if this was a life or death situation but it's not
a life or death situation it is now uhoh he do it
too I don't I don't doubt him come on guys what
are you crazy it's just a dummy grenade no it's
not oh he's costing the school a lot
of money concentrate to finally what
the hell was that it's like a super
laxative this here will pack enough
punch to take out entire football team oh
that is messed up P will never get off the
can he'll be made beef sto till graduation
these kids could easily be misconstrued for
something else in in the wrong context
so I don't know what you're talking
[Music]
about I mean in a weird way he's bringing
in the unit together because they all
have a common enemy which is him yeah
it's very true there's a call for you
sir oh he knows what's [Music]
up look at them they're strategizing
yeah uh-oh now do you think bring them together by
making Comm common enemy as his his intention or
just like the adverse effect of what he's trying
to I think adverse yeah I think the ladder there's
a surprising amount of heart there's actual
story here yeah I thought it would just be
a bunch of silly gags based off the front cover
no yeah it's it's we I like the team we have so
far and there a narrative here exactly yeah I
feel like having these kids there balances out
from his ridiculousness uhoh things about to get
shitty damn he swallowed that whole He golfed that
down it's not going to work that
fast come on no way for the sake
of a comedy erron and the name of comedy
in the name of Comedy super fast acting
laxatives don't give him you're giving him the
look knowing that you the one
who did it oh you can take it
get he's trained for this my man his
body's probably immune Heats poisons for
fun that was well well edited that was great
cut to the Wi happens that was really well
timed I keep wondering if this guy's GNA be
if he's like the villain of the movie or if
he's going to amount to like being some kind
of leader like a real leader feel like he's
going to be the leader um I feel he's going
to go through something that humbles him and
then makes him the real leader I'm actually
curious about where the story is going to
go hours he hasn't [Laughter] blinked love how
exaggerated of a Lethal Weapon he [Laughter] is
he's killing machine this one's prettier man you
sure about this he looks away to me I checked
[Laughter] on see he's dead to the
world let's go visual gag works so
well because of the breathing up and
down of the stomach right get in can
I just stand beside the bed get in oh
jeez this is going to backfire so stupid
you shouldn't do his kids don't do it he's
going to he's going to punish you guys so
bad this is such a terrible IDE
day how is he not woken up
okay he's faking he has to be
closer now put your arm around oh jeez come on
guys
[Laughter] [Applause] I love
how delicately they close the
tripod so [Music]
funny ma major a major a when we that's squat
when we piss I tell you ladies you're the Prest
unit ever underneath my command I think he's
really whipping them into shape though really
making them a unit his unorthodox methods I
thought we had a little talk about this kind
of negative reinforcement she going to be my
big helper yeah but they started it don't No
don't touch my whistle touch the whistle they
may not like me but they will respect me let
me be more direct they hate you good draw them
close together make them a team aha attention
i' would like you to consider an alternative
approach I want you to have this book role model
the ABCs of the loving male role model I don't
need your book take it I don't want it take it
I don't want it please major take it doesn't
matter even if you know she's faking just do
it the power of Seduction I mean they need to
be punished for what they did I mean they are
technically yeah I I'm not really on her side
on this one they got to maybe even worse I feel
like in real life someone did that they'd be
punished much worse than just having to wear
dresses he's getting more into the book
surpris is actually reading it I just
came by to let you know that williger has a
slight temperature so you might not want to
torture him this evening I will be sensitive to
his needs pointing in the machete have you been
reading the book well I might have glanced
at it once or twice well that's very good
I'm very proud of you m it's such a child oh
come on he's back he's back he's all around
the man myet boy get on out of here with that
I'm scared of crap go on now get but this is
not military training hello there fella it's
called a nightmare why don't you run on back
to your room for that man jump at the CL and
CH your little head off halfway there progress
s let me give you a little history on
Kevin Dunn car accident 1989 lived in
the chest that often is till 1991 when
the school adopted him I know all about
it he needs right now is a sadistic Father
Figure scaring the life out of him it's not
sadistic he's toughing him up get him to
ready for the future out and let boy grow
up they're going to learn from each other
stop babying him I don't call it babying
I call it nurturing and I call you an insecure
overbearing Psychopathic dictatorial eom mancal
Frid lunatic [__] he's still there you want
to see nurturing uh-oh uhoh he in there oh
no oh jeez heing there he ain't happy m yeah it
happened P just terminate that Batman with extreme
prejudice and if he still in there he ain't happy
way to solve the problem you got to shoot your way
out of things b b ain't going to bother you
no more thank you major a I love [Laughter]
you a great reaction let's go your angle
boy you plotting on me snap your neck at 20
different places major major it's okay he's just
trying to show you some affection I don't like
it [Laughter]
bul uhoh uhoh she's falling for the softness in
him good night Miss there's a boy underneath that
rough exterior I have to fix him says something
about her if she's falling for him you know right
this teaches women the wrong lesson this is
why they fall into abusive toxic relationships
gaslighters she's anxious and he's avoidant
yeah she's trying to fix him can't fix it's
not Good's not here he's in our ass is our
ass so tight he gas so tight he can't pass
gas get it you got
moves who's this
[__] ooh Steve Austin all right he's a little
thick for Steve Austin John [Laughter] Goodman
yo you pain I got something to say to you
that's not JN [Laughter] good what be you
did he hire this guy to whoop his ass to get
respect I hope so you know I heard you've been
giving these boys a hard time in fact I heard
you couldn't cut it in a real man's military
I think he hired him I heard your mother she
played pool with the [Music] planets ooo you
thinking about leaving yet well actually I think
the party just begun it's exactly what he's
been looking for right he's been thirsty
for [Music] it there you go there you go
said you going to hit me in the
face what you calling me a [Music]
li somebody's going to answer for this blood
from my lip I want names all of them I guess
nobody's responsible guess I just had that one
of coming well you know what y'all got coming
7 20 three hour days full of fun and Adventure I'm
going to make you boy strong it was me sir I hired
him well that's one death warrant son I acted
alone sir the rest of the squad was unaware of
my activities he's taking the fall within that's
not true is it it's not true I don't think so he's
the leader selflessness that's it sure sir you
are no longer the squad leader what stone you are
now Cadet sergeant if these men win the Virginia
Military games it'll be because you had led them
to a victory ooh that's a nice turn yeah if they
lose it'll be because you failed them I like how
major P are have such a caricature and then he's
become like a real character yeah yeah like the
the character aspect is just a facade facade
but like to disguise what the actual character
is like H in high order raising the bar I
feel like they really had to train these
kids before doing this comedy oh yeah there's
like a lot of physicality invol I want that
trophy if your tur can bring me that trophy I
will resign my command if you are discovered I
will deny all knowledge and you will pay the
price damn he's a really good leader yeah he
knows what he's doing we got two miles to get
to Willington let's get in out of there as fast
as we can let's hustle move it go look at that
he's becoming he doesn't even realize it what
you think I'm going to come and help you make
me look bad anyway I've called my dad leaving
this stupid School you salty little baby I'm
going to the blackout you can't come you're
too little why don't you stay back here and guard
the base okay young Orlando Brown kid from fresh
prella whoever you are what's the matter with you
boy they won't let me going to Black Op they say
I'm too little what about all the stories about
the little people that do big things Little Red
Riding Hood Three Little Pigs [__] Le or them
little rasers you ever hear the story about The
Little Engine That Could let me tell you that
story this it going to be accurate he's using
some of that softness some of that sensitivity
training he was chugging his way across the enemy
line this little engine mission was to take some
AK47s that was pled opposition you
think that stopped The Little Engine
That cut no he just kept chugging
along she comes at the right time
Dam wow look how soft he can be
popped out the eyes of conductor
blood did that stop the in the C damn
skip me he just kept chugging along
CH it wasn't until Charlie rigged
the bridge with plastic explosive
uhoh just as The Little Engine
was making his way across the
dresser blood and gut and spitting ass was
every everywhere I can't feel my legs they
ain't there I look down and them little bloody
n was kicking real fast 30 miles did a Nast T
unless you can flip upside down and work on
your head you ain't going to make it how many
stories is he combining just me and my side and
I had no other alternative but the blast my way
out B I saw what you
did this went so South so fast you just
missed a little bedtime story no I didn't
actually I'd love to talk to you about
that story perhaps over dinner oh snap
drawn to the pain this is not going to be
healthy relationship I want to do the sequel
to this that does a very realistic take
on it where they be at in 30 years from
now oh my God he changed this
is not the place to have a quiet
conversation God damn
as you do I think Damon wayes really
had to scarf all that down and they
just sped it up how many takes
you're right that was almost
a really good thing you tried to
do for Tiger tonight they make a
suggestion proceed well your story while
colorful bit rough you mean explosion yes
and the context the gouging part you need
to loosen up not everything can be about
war she likes him for his [Music] potential it's
dangerous territory I like to hang upside down
blindfold and then I take my gunot and I put it
back together real fast before my nose start to
bleed but is there anything that you like
that doesn't have to do with battle like golf
negative dance I don't suppose you dance I dance
in [Music] Vietnam I've been
known to cut a little rug in my
day oh no
is a you
dance stop judging him that's how
he dances he's expressing himself
he can pop and luck stun double it [Laughter]
[Music]
to he's the constant center of
attention
okay there you go that's something you can do
together oh no
R yeah get it pop it the hell was up you
take these guys and fan out the Left Flank
of the school go got you take these two and
cover the right got it got she can heal him
and make him softer him major pain this
guy's doing great oh yeah he's killing him
man come on realize you want to win it
the right way oh no you're going to get
caught oh is it the [Music] principal
janitor don't move he's going to get
[Music] expelled yeah we faster than that man run
[Music] dang don't abandon them oh
yeah you're done oh [__] you're
done in rings oh no maybe that one kid
that stayed behind can help them I keep
trying to figure out how smart major pain
actually is where how much just happens by
chance I got something for you oh what
is it it's a bullet it's from my heart
literally he survived well where'd you get
it from my heart left ventricle I took it
out myself with a field knife he's such a
great military man and they just threw him
[Music] away terrible the beginning of a long
30 years terrible idea is this really the man
you'd want to raise your children with what the
hell are you doing in my office it was a trap you
set us up I might have made a little Anonymous
call oh we got the crap kicked out of us because
of you tonight wasn't about Fair unfair it was
about achieving your objective did you even see
that trophy hey I did did you want it I wanted
it to own it yeah deserve it yeah to win it oh
yeah he's got him if you really want it I'll show
you how to earn it he's going to shoot major pain
right now what the hell happened to you Michael
Ironside what are you doing here it's parents day
and I am your legal guardian oh God drunk don't
you walk away from me give me a little salute
I'm not going to salute you he feels like Jack
Nicholson you Salute Your superiors what Superior
they kicked you out remember don't you sass me
like your mother this just got very real yeah
I own you and you will respect me damn now you
salute me no you hit that boy again again I'mma do
more than salute you this is between me and my son
stepson whoever he is he's on my time now that man
sweating hell yeah kick his ass pay yeah
please return to your vehicle Smart they
needed like a serious moment yeah an hour and
10 minutes into the movie get your one serious
Mo now you understand why he is the way that
he is major pain sir thank you I want to get
that trophy sir even better for me but you
won't steal it no sir you want to win it I
want to earn it sir that's right rest of you
men feel the same way yeah I guess so yeah
suppos way I guess that one kid not really
but like all right since everyone else said
it a this is a sweet movie other
than the whole future domestic
violent relationship that's happen that's a later
problem eat eat like you've never
eaten before this going to be a fun
game we're ever going to watch
I think they should end on in
like an ambiguous way right before
the game starts just cut to Black
[Music] oh I want to do some military
training N I know that sounds way too
tiring can barely get out of bed oh oh no oh
[__] oh [__] what just happened they got
twins oh no there's two of them okay oh
yeah the Death guy pass got it you look
so racist jeez Aaron godamn it
oh little man city just a little
bit damn Aaron you know we can't say that in this
video in major trouble major be a pain for the ad
suitability [Laughter] a he's willing to share
his whistle blow my whistle baby oh what why is
this becoming like a real movie they didn't even
hear the dialogue that's crazy that's just visual
storytelling right there I didn't sign up for real
emotions cute moment this just turned into like a
real fil moments like that why she stays that's
how you hook him just got to apologize I've seen
the Priscilla Elvis movie still a [__] sandwich
you're just not a soggy one that's means you got
good feces turds you've graduated strong stools
to maggots from turds to maggots let's win them
games these games better be awesome there's been
so much hype and buildup to this you better not
lose we need you back but he can't go back he
loves these kids now America needs you there's
a situation in that requires your special
services no I can't I love them now your
unit will be leaving out of Washington you
will arrive tomorrow at 1600 for briefing
but here are your T but the kids uh tomorrow the
military games and I was hoping games I fought
to get you reinstated you want it in I got you
in oh man conflict the major will be there sir
good man I'll see you in Washington all right
peace out kids I mean half of them have daddy
issues you might as well just reaffirm
he can be their daddy older male mentors
will abandon you they will not stick around
continue that cycle I overheard that whole
conversation me leaving is training you to be
tougher where you going back to killing you
want to come oh damn what happened to Unity and
family and all that other [__] that you taught
us I never said family don't break up don't you
watch Oprah you know when they're through with
you they're just going to cut you loose again
I asked to leave boys making me soft them boys
need you I need you look woman T 11 separate
engagements I didn't do all that to come back
and be conquered by no woman and a bunch of
kids what you really think I was going to do
marry you ouch adopt tiger become the loving
male role model that's not me it's not me pain
this is called is pain Dark Knight of the Soul
people screen writer ladies and gentlemen every
big movie Falls the same structure pretty much
it's why most movies are predictable [Laughter]
now all that growth what was it for major pain
what was it for major pen just to regress I
can't believe he actually left Alex where are you
going he had to run from his feelings it wasn't
personal games you guys better start getting
ready we got to be there in an hour we don't
have to go to games P's gone he's gone until he
shows up at the last minute to support you guys
pain or no pain I'm going to go out there
and win that stupid trophy pain or no pain
we got to gain the trophy I didn't go through
all that to come out empty-handed AR you with
me I can't hit you yes sir he really
does have big ears you can't help it
Greg present arms stap present Arington
present why someone like this some like
this what's up pick one Madison present
arms Cadet order arms the Virginia
jroy got nothing to save you bage
come on oh forgot about this game
that's a hard game it's all about the
strats The Leverage the grip damn poor
kid surprisingly good
transition that is not a white picket fence
it's really it's really messed up fence
it's really ugly Rock oh from Tiger my f get
son I wish tiger got the bullets out of that
closet there it is
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
boy it's [Music] laughing
you know what you must do he
be honorably [Music] discharged
damn kid get it kid come a long
way oh I have never been good at rope
climbing he's over the wall go oh
these like buot cab drill stuff are
was really fun did tough mutter once
that was really fun it going be really
fun CL thing I've done this is
football training my man get
it you going to trip him wow [__] dude
cheer winner of the races when did he switch sides
I don't think he did fourth [Applause] place you
traitor oh dang I guess what the hell you guys got
to conduct yourselves in a professional [Music]
manner damn he's great I demand that the entire
medicine Squad be disqualified from the final
competition I can only disqualify the cadet who
started the disturbance these animals are so
pathetic their on Commander didn't bother to
show [Music] up ain't no need for name colge
good man good man who whoa whoa whoa who I
suggest we get this party started that okay
with you Colonel I'm pleased to announce the two
top rated squads who will compete for first and
second place in the parade drill competition o
here we go Wellington Academy and Madison Academy
I would have ended this on a much darker note
where he shows up right when they lose so was
all for nothing you're pathetic now to give them
some nice morale in their loss lick their wounds
for next year I weirdly have a lot of thoughts
about this movie that I want to share when the
reaction's done so why'd you come back be soft
be soft maybe I didn't come back for you Why'd
You Come Back Then for my boy and my woman I
told myself that I want to see you win first
place and ain't going to leave till you do it's
all about the trophy maybe I like you just like
maybe I like you a lot that's it don't push
the baby let's win this thing we have nobody
to lead the drill of course we do tiger he's
little that boy know the drill like the knob
on the back head I can't do it I'm too little
you got this little little Bloom you were The
Little Engine That Could you're going to shoot
up this place real team leader private Kevin
DK I think it's like a real a good
comedy and I feel like it had the
potential to be like a great comedy
if they just tweaked a couple of
things adorable little
[Music]
guy
good job kids I want to look up
the trivia on this movie yeah I'm
really curious what happened to all these
actors come on come on yeah he got you
tapping oh my goodness hey oh my goodness
oh my goodness this why he was hired damn
is this real that looks real that's yeah
he's doing it for real that's awesome
damn that's
awesome yeah Pump It show how it's
done get it
yeah your daddy taught you that that was
so funny never forget it the kid was so
committed Orlando Bloom kid from Fresh prins So
committ or from that so raven or TMZ slash three
months later oh yeah this teacher what a the
random teacher with the bugs the dean there's
a Korean flag there there's a Mex California
flag Mexico flag I don't know I figure what
the flags look like did they win yeah good job
good job guys you're better than your abusive
stepfather sir Squad is formed sir my name is
Major Benson Winford pain Winford I'd like for
you to think of me not only as your commanding
officer but as your friend and what the hell
is that he's mine uhoh oh that's cool he's the
next potential leader of this squad or he just
an [__] you know there ain't no pets allowed
on these head premises Mr Ace ventur yeah well
maybe that doesn't apply to me he's my blind cing
ey dog oh he's blind well would anybody want with
a blind dog I'm the one that's blind you idiot
see you and your friend gujo here got a little
attitudinal problem needs some readjusting
hey corpit corpit go tell Mom bring my fi KN
mom what do you care you're
blun kind of a creep creepy ass way to end the
movie really I thought I thought they going do
the circle in like a Looney Tune thing okay that
interesting it was Orlando Brown I called it he
is problems all right reject Nation so today I
want to share something with you that has been
a wonderful addition to my health and fitness
journey that I discovered during the holidays
and that is liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm
down to my very last packet and I'm freaking out
but it's okay I got more in the mail now a lot of
you have been so kind kind to notice how I've been
working on my physical health thank you for all
the compliments and one thing I learned is that
proper hydration is absolutely crucial especially
post-workout and pre-filming after post-workout
and my wife actually introduced me to this product
which is perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good taste and quality product
whether it's after a sweaty workout or just
after you know a good night out you know what
I'm saying efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolites is key you just feel better and it
tastes fantastic I can't emphasize that enough
another thing I'm always on the lookout for too is
products that have zero sugar or zero sugar added
because that's one of my main dietary restrictions
throughout the week and they of course got
products that fit that description that also taste
good too so yes thank you so much so liquid IV's
hydration multiplier is in summary is they are a
non-GMO electrolyte drink that delivers hydration
into your blood stream faster and more efficient
than water alone cuz sometimes drinking a whole
gallon is not always efficient but in fact it
can provide the same hydration as drinking two to
three bottles of water I'm also big on efficiency
plus it's packed with love essential vitamins and
we know vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy free you
can customize the water amount to your taste again
perfect for post night recovery traveling or just
having a big night out you know what I mean no so
if you want to booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid i.com and use
promo code reject at checkout that's liquid iv.com
promo code Rejects and remember liquid IV it's
not a real IV sure feels like it so stay hydrated
stay healthy and let's keep crushing those health
and fitness goals together in the year 2024 all
righty guys a classic one jeez Aaron I'm trying
to say the thing say the thing if you're listening
this on Apple or Spotify I'm paying Aaron for
2 hours and we got 21 minutes I'm going to get
every minute out of you Aaron I don't care what we
filled this with we just watched major pain today
and Aon what was your expectations before going
into this this comedy uh my expectations were a
zil a zero um uh and you know what they exceeded
them they exceeded they they met they became an
expect they met them and uh they did so adequately
uh I liked it I thought it was fun I I definitely
see why people like this movie uh it had heart you
know even though that major pain was definitely
on the outside this character of this tough and
Military guy there was heart there there was like
a layer of real character there underneath all
of the uh the not satire but this like SNL esque
exaggerated character and seeing him play against
these kids who also had their own individual
things going on but primarily Stone and tiger um
yeah it was it was a nice fun movie I like the
music I think that is there two no there's not up
random uh yeah Damon Waynes really made this movie
he was hilarious from start to finish you would
think that the stick that he was doing would get
old but it strangely didn't I laughed through from
start to finish and for a movie to be almost 20
almost 30 Jesus almost 30 years old it came out in
1995 the year I was born uh it yeah for it still
to hold up is just a testament to the quality
of the writing uh because you know we go through
movies that are of their time you know each decade
has their own genre of humor uh that it kind of
sticks with and or plays with and some sometimes
it works in future sometimes it doesn't and this
for the most part worked uh yeah I thought all
the acting was really good I really like the girl
who played Hillary I cannot remember her name U
do you remember that girl's name dude of course
I committed it to memory the only remembered is
Stone and major pain and tiger and that's pretty
much it uh but yeah I was thoroughly entertained
I don't think it's like the greatest comedy I've
ever seen but it's it's fun you know it's harmless
it was what what's her name Ken Parson Karen
Parsons she's still fine yeah she's still hot
damn I know getting off track but damn Godot damn
woman uh yeah it had a lot more heart than
expected I got a theory for you you have a
theory I was just having a random guest when I was
watching I was like okay all the posters for major
pain uh he's turned profiled right looking over
at us that way yeah his reaction like it's a very
specific kind of poster and then I started looking
at all the other posters I started looking on like
okay is this the original poster and it is the
original poster and my theory is they had maybe
some marketing thing where they didn't really want
the gold tooth showing yeah because they were like
they might be unappealing for audiences to look
at and they might not want to see it and get the
wrong impression might scare them might scare
them with a black man with a gold tooth might
offend uh military people and I went a different
direction you did yeah I went with the black thing
in the military maybe both maybe it could be both
it could be both all right so here before there's
a okay IMDb has five facts one of them is really
long so I I I want to get my thoughts first okay
then I want to go through these facts I got you
for 17 more minutes here and Counting I've been
going to go to the bathroom the last 40 minutes oh
really but I'm hold it in oh God cuz every minute
with you counts for this two hour are your Bells
okay uh yeah I'm with you I I I I thought it would
be a little bit more like hideen spoof satire I
mean there's there's that uh spoof satire element
throughout obviously with like making fun of
uh drill sergeants and specifically the kind
of like drill sergeants that you would see in uh
Cinema like I don't really know what a real drill
Sergeant's like I know they're riing on real drill
sergeant but my only Association is with movies
and this this movie is like making fun of like
that type in a movie if you're like what if you
took this guy and you put him in this scenario and
I thought they did a really fun job with that and
to liken it to like a a comedy today I would kind
of liken a little bit more to like weirdly you
don't have you seen you Don't Mess with the Zohan
Adam S no actually never seen it well while it's
like a super silly film uh Adam Sandler really
did like Israeli military training for it really
bulked up for this film about this lethal Israeli
War uh military man who comes to the States to
become a hair stylist but he but he really got
buff for it and he he did all the actual training
and everything like they he really did all that
and I got the impression that they kind of did
the same thing here that while it is a comedy
they still had them go through rigorous training
I imagine even Damen ways probably did like a
decent amount of actual research because one
of my favorite things about it was it did start
off where I had that same feeling like okay this
is funny now but is this going to get annoying
watching this one note and then they managed to
make major pain become a real character through
the course of the film and they they never had it
go too far yeah which I really liked where he gets
like way too soft by the end or some [__] it was
believable yeah and then they had some surprising
heartfelt nuanced moments where there could be a
little bit of a serious scene with major pain
there and you could believe the serious scene
despite how heightened this character is there's
some good visual gags throughout I mean eron and
I were joking about the this kind of relationship
[__] is the thing that's just not believable and
get ridiculed today for you know falling in love
with the man who would probably be a real abusive
kind of lover but it's stupid silly comedy what
do you what does it matter I do think that yeah
overall the end goal of the movie is to make you
laugh and I I laughed quite a bit it wasn't like
I was laughing a little bit and then suddenly I
stopped like this was a movie that one of my I
think my biggest laugh actually came from the the
Orlando Bloom Miss tiger at the end when he was
doing the Michael Jackson dad like that [__] was
cracking me up that's like towards the very end of
the film so yeah I thought it was a really fun
movie and I could see how this is one that could
probably feed into a lot of people's Nostalgia
who grew up on it but this is us discovering it
and normally I I kind of separate myself going
yeah there's like a Nostalgia film and then
there's this this is today as a new viewers like
whatever uh I I thought it would be more annoying
for some reason I've seen this poster for so much
of my life never seen a clip or a trailer and I I
always thought it might be a bit of an annoying
film even though I've liked the weins family
and in like almost everything I see them in so I
don't know why I I I like watch My Wife and Kids
and uh I watched um uh Wayne's Brothers as well
uh both those shows and then while they while
the movies and I've seen some of their sketches
from In Living Color and I've seen a good amount
of their movies as well and Damon way is one who
like went off into being a director he like direct
Scary Movie one and two I did not know that oh wow
yeah yeah he's mainly he's directed A lot of them
of the the ones that SAR Marlin and Shawn wayes
he's directed a good amount of them huh yeah so
he's he's kept him there kep in the family right
right let me before I'm before I'm really wrong
I think I'm just going off memory here I I could
be wrong because so many there's so many weighin
brothers that I probably I'm wondering if I'm
wrong about that four of them and then the a
big Wayne's Brothers family no no I'm wrong who's
the keen and ivory Waynes is the one I'm thinking
of keen and ivory way my bad yeah no Keen IV way
is the one who went off and directed my bad okay
glad I clear once I started saying I was like no
wait a minute I think I'm off about that se The
Last Boy Scout um but yeah I've seen the sketch
Living Color I forgot that he's not the one I
want off to what did Keenan I wayin do he we got
I think he was In Living Color we got 13 minutes
Aon I'm going to look up what Keenan I Wayne's
did he he's done a lot of stuff I know he used
to do more stuff in the 90s being on camera but
not as much yes he's the one who's like directs
white chicks and that's right my bad I got it
confus w okay the last yeah okay glad we are
here to where where is it the director director
little man white chick Scary Movie Scary Movie 2
oh they brought back In Living Color that's right
I forgot about that they did yeah look 2012 forgot
they did that actually I didn't forget clearly
didn't last long I did not know that um but yeah
uh I think D way and Damon way has a kid who's
also called Damon wayes right yeah Damon way Jr
yes she new girl yes yes yes yes okay there's a
lot of Wayne's Brothers there's a lot of it's a
big Wayne's family wayman's of them and there's
the next generation of Wayne there just the ones
you know about that's true all right Aaron we
got 11 and a half minutes left I'm going to
look up how many wein what is the size of the wein
family that's not the way to ask the question but
let's see if this Google knows what I'm talking
about come on Google come on AI I should have
said how many members are in the we's family
be a lot 10 siblings damn see five brothers and
Five Sisters that's a shitload of kids look at
that look at that poor mother Keenan Ivory sha
Marlon Damon and Dwayne Wayne who the hell is
Dwayne he's like I want no part of this family
business who is Dwayne wein oh [__] he's a real
human being it's been a long time since I've seen
White Chicks but did that movie have heart do you
remember kind of because what what makes me think
of that is you know this movie had that balance
of him being a caricature and and over the course
of the movie developing heart and being like a a
real guy to some extent but I'm like watching it
and he has the these his scenes where he does
his like his bits you know like the The Little
Engine That Could and like the whole dancing
aspect of things or the that one scene but you
know it doesn't feel like how they would try to do
comedy in the 2000s it still felt of the 90s but
it wasn't overbearing no still in that that realm
of like okay this is still entertaining this is
still funny rather than trying too hard to be like
ha you get it we're doing a bit well here's what
I think would have helped elevate this movie from
being a like a good comedy to a masterpiece of a
film I'm here to tell you how this could have
been maybe the greatest movie ever made ER I I
don't I don't mean to oversell but I think I can
deliver the goods what they could have done is a
I think we they could have had a little more of
those Nuance serious doesn't have to be serious
but not go for like go for the laughs uh when
you're just cutting to the kids when they're by
themselves that way we can really get to know the
children so you have a contrast when you cut to
major pain where you're kind of in a different
type of like Wacky World and then you're in a
world with the kids where you get a little bit
more of getting to know their personality is where
they come from why they're here why they are the
way they are like that the whole thing with the
kid and his stepfather comes in like pretty late
into the movie and kind of getting an inkling of
that for the character Arc probably would have
helped serve the narrative a little bit better
you know and I feel like that one ingredient would
have helped flush all this out because this whole
thing about the games I'm like I don't really
know what what the I know the game's it's more
than just like a trophy there's there's got to
be a deeper meaning to it than that you know but
why and I think if if they had and I thought this
movie at times was a little bit at odds of wanting
to just be that wacky comedy because there's three
screenwriters here so I thought at times it was
that odds would wanting to be the wacky comedy
that as advertised and then oh but you know we
really do want a little more Harden to be kind of
like Kindergarten Cop or something I don't know
one one of those movies where you get more Nuance
to to so you're more connected to the kids yeah
and and I think that was the missing ingredient
because I'm like I don't really know who the
the kids personalities is that well other than
you only know like three of them you know tiger
the guy the one who's the douche who leaves them
and then the main guy right and but everyone else
even has like a camaraderie and stuff like I think
there were felt like there was like missing scenes
or stuff that they just rewrote or cut out where
if we got more of I guess what I'm talking about
is like whenever you're cutting with them that's
where you really get a start growing the heart for
it so you care more about major pain connecting
with them you know and then I think they could
have perhaps dialed back a tiny tiny bit towards
the end like just get a inkling more of who major
pain is not a lot I'm not saying a lot but when
they have these opportunities when he's bonding
with Hillary whatever her name is he's bonding
with with the girl from freshz uh if you got a
tiny bit more of like beyond the military yeah
and something from his childhood yeah I'm not
saying you have to go like deep psychoanalysis
or some [__] but the the movie was obviously
wanting to to go in that terrain I think the
movie wanted to like that's why they have the
book about emotional nurturing being an adult
male role model reading a psychology book they
have like these when he first argues with Hillary
when they first have a blowout just dropping like
these adjectives of like real psychoanalysis term
you know so I think the movie actually wanted to
sort of explore that and they were kind of I don't
know it's the 90s I don't know how [__] worked
back then so maybe they were told to like you know
temper it hold it back be more fun you know I I I
have no idea uh but I do think more of the the
heart wanted to be there kind of threw out and
they were kind of told not to or they were told
to edit it out because especially with like Damon
Wayne's being a co-writer and and like the main
thing I love from him all most people love like
In Living Color or the other things he's done um
some people even liked him in the Lethal Weapon
show the the I I know him for My Wife and Kids
mainly like specifically this Wayne's brother I
know him for my wife and kids which is a very
heartfelt show about family and it was really
funny and I really liked it and I I think that
this movie is actually Shining a lot when they
are doing more of the the stuff with Hillary so
bad forget your name wrong stuff with her I think
that's when they were definitely um showing a
little they're not like a husband and wife but
that's when you start seeing the the relationship
side of it and then with tiger the father side the
stuff that really shines in my wife and kids and
this is on My Wife and Kids production so clearly
this is this is a that is a theme in a topic when
it comes to narrative storytelling that Damon ways
himself is very much drawn to so maybe there was
a specific script and Dam ways came in and said we
should Implement some of this or maybe there was
an inverse I don't know either way I think if they
had more of that it would have helped make the
wackier stuff even funnier yeah you know and they
would have had some actual stakes and investment
in the game because even the movie when they're
done with the game they just dissolve too and
they you don't get a wrap up on on our kids no
when I'm like oh that's kind of a bummer to me you
know or or even with Hillary God damn it yeah they
kind of they kind they did kind of treat them as
a bit of an afterthought yeah cuz we they start
to do that in the beginning like okay these are
these kids different personalities as he's like
giving them their their uh their punishment for
their acting out or whatever and yeah we start
to see some of that like the like the thick kid
who was eating the the cookies and stuff I would
have liked to see more of him and like the the
kid who had the his head shaved who had the big
ears and like yeah I agree that camaraderie
would have made things a little bit stronger
and I I would have liked to know more about
Hillary too or whatever the hell her name is
um and you know maybe her relationship with with
tiger you know and then that adds and plays into
their perspective of the the whole family thing
because the way that it ended where major pain
leaves it just treated them as the focus for that
one scene or that one segment of the movie and
then ending it Without Really seeing where they
go cuz there some of them are still in the line
like uh at the end of the movie and just ending
it on major pain not really showing the followup
of what happens with him and Hillary what happens
with him and Tiger's relationship what happens to
the team as a whole I would have liked to seen all
of that and yeah that's it's unfortunate but may
hey maybe left on The Cutting Room floor maybe
they're like all right this is a 90s movie we
got to wrap it up yeah you got time for none of
that uh let's see here okay I'm going to look at
re I'm speed reading some quick facts here all
right to research his character Damon Wayne's
endured several weeks of di qualification training
learning the requirements to Marine Corps drill
instructor as well as other aspects of Marine
Corps training viewers can see several small
things he does like the Cadence of his walk see
this is the thing I'm talking about where I'm like
I felt like he actually prepared for the role and
that's what I mean like you wouldn't just do that
for just a wacky comedy I think there was more
care in there that they wanted to implement along
with the wackiness you know almost unconsciously
correcting his cover after berading and getting
in the face of each Cadet and the list goes on
and the b list basically just goes on the stage
is how much more he uh he stayed in there and even
improvising he was a lot of it was embodying the
character all right okay there's actual accuracy
to the uniform he's wearing one of the kids is the
one he says um he says I'm not your brother that
is actually deak Williams that is Damen Wayne's
nephew oh cool usually put their kids in there
it's cheap cheapap cheap cheap let's see here uh
Dam Wayne's character was dancing to Pop That
Coochie by two two Live Crew in the nightclub
scene uh interestingly enough Waynes was having
a real life Feud with two life crew at the time
due to a joke he told about the group during his
comedy special oh way to rub it in their face I
liked hearing you readed Pop That Coochie that was
funny um yeah hey Aaron we got two minutes left uh
Martin Lawrence was offered the role of major pain
but turned it down cuz he was making bad boys with
slap artist Will Smith I could have totally seen
him as major pain too he would have been great
uhuh let me just go no was this one a minute and
a half left okay pH I like the score too I thought
the score was was fitting oh check this out in
interview with is true it's good a good point
on the on the score here um in an interview Damon
Wayne said that at the beginning of filming he was
advised by technical adviser Dale D to meth act
and dist himself from the kids in the R Group when
the camera wasn't rolling similar to what Lou go
Jr had done and An Officer and a Gentleman see I
think they wanted to make a real movie right you
don't make those choices for that kind of [__]
that kind of preparation for a pure comedy no I
got those inklings of like the filmmaker or the
writing that probably had Studio notes to I don't
know just keep it keep it simple or something keep
it light uh but no yeah cuz that they get heavy
with the steps dad coming in slapping the kid
around like this is rather Ser this like serious
this is dramatic scene that was the most serious
thing that happened in the movie it was like
a little jarring for to go like that real and
then go back to to the tone we were expecting we
were used to but uh overall with what we got the
product ultimately delivered was a funny film and
I'm glad we saw it and we got to experience the
Nostalgia a lot of people get a experience we
got 40 seconds left here um this video itself
will not be two hours but the recording is two
hours got to get that who's your favorite weigh
in Marlin wow done the most well just by quantity
not by quality of an artist he's done the most
he's bidden more things he's my favorite by that
measure I'd be like Nicholas Cage is my between
Marlin and him because I grew up on him and
uh all my wife and kids he's he's a classic I
miss him I wish he'd come back Damon we miss you
still does stuff when was the last time you saw
him in something oh two hours up all right thank
you guys so much for being here uh leave a like
And subscribe and we'll catch youall soon I gotta
get him out of here before he charges me more you
know M Lyon hey M M M it's a new year in Sweden or
Switzerland I don't know it's been a couple years
I always forget which one they sound the same to
me I don't know what they look like I don't know
what what you sound like I don't I don't know the
difference what is he Sweden I think he is Swedish
wait did you forget I you remember it was like you
said both names so many times he was like doing
the shell game I was like where is the Pete uh yes
he's he's in Sweden I I yeah my mind leans towards
Sweden every time but I constantly question it
because I'm like I don't know what Switzerland
or Sweden looks like and I don't know what what
the difference is because I don't know what any I
don't know anything about you guys sure and you've
educated us before but it's all left my dumb
American brain once a year you should come back
here and educate us on your culture anyway look
you got to have a New Year's resolution regardless
right you you swits must do that you must have
don't celebrate the new year or sweet yeah you
you must have a you must have a New Year's plans
so here's your New Year's resolution I'm going
to give it to you because I know you probably
haven't thought of it cuz you guys down and uh uh
Estonia never think about it right you Romanians
man oh so what your shout out is your your New
Year's resolution um oh I knew exactly what was
going to be all right um You are going to buy many
mirrors you're going to set up many mirrors that
way when someone breaks into your home to try to
shoot you you can do the taunting monologue game
oh yeah and you can like flip around and be like
where am I now and then there'll be surrounded
by mirrors and then they shoot at you and but it
cracks with you don't Flinch they sh that wasn't
you they shot they shot the mirror not you and
you give a laugh and you step out of frame and
leave them to languish hit them over the oh yeah
that no no no in confusion before you hit them
over the head hit them over the head yeah you
sneak up on them that's when you get the drop
but you see the thing is like you know the problem
is in these like spy and action movies that you're
obsessed with uh male is like they don't prepare
for a scenario when do they ever take the time for
a training session to learn how why is it always
they know how to manipulate the mirror situation
but the bad guys don't know how to manipulate the
mirror situation so you got to train you really
got to train to figure out how the mirrors bounce
off each other to be able to properly manipulate
and trick the the bad guy when they break into
your home of how to you know scare them yeah you
need to learn the layout of the you need to spend
a month living in complete dark so you know the
lay out just instinctually and then you need to
do a lot of different studies on yeah what angles
are the best what looks the most cinematic because
the thing is if you're going to mess with you know
like a a a burglar coming in you can't just do it
in a normal efficient way you have to taunt them
and make it clear that you're the boss and they
messed up by coming into your domain and please do
not for the love of God please do not attack until
they say where are you yeah it's very that's the
most important part facts this sh yeah dude there
you go man Mel seriously all right you're the best
Norwegian we know best Norwegian all right you
take care of your Viking sisters and brothers out
there and you let us know how everything is going
and uh Happy New Year te you buddy [Music] yeah